Hallo zusammen. Ich bin Peter
und ich bin ein Süchtiger.
(Alle) Hallo Peter.
Zuerst der Moment der Stille
für die noch leidenden Süchtigen
und für diejenigen, die heute
an ihrer Sucht gestorben sind.
Um uns daran zu erinnern,
woher wir kommen.
* Dynamische, perlende Klänge *
Narcotics Anonymous, kurz NA,
ist die zweitgrösste
Selbsthilfegruppe der Welt.
Entstanden ist sie in den USA
aus den Anonymen Alkoholikern,
der grössten Selbsthilfegruppe.
Weltweit gibt es 70'000 NA-Meetings
pro Woche.
Allein in Zürich
finden täglich mehrere Treffen statt.
Einzige Bedingung für die Teilnahme
ist der Wunsch,
mit Drogen aufzuhören.
Mit Drogen ist auch Alkohol gemeint.
Es ist ein Programm
völliger Abstinenz.
Viele Meetings sind offen
für Angehörige, Fachpersonen -
und für Journalistinnen wie mich.
Mein Name ist Alex
und ich bin ein Süchtiger.
(Alle) Hallo Alex.
Ich begann sehr früh,
Drogen zu nehmen.
Bei mir war das Alkohol mit 13.
Und ich habe es v.a. ... Klar war es
auch Party, Festen und Spass haben.
Aber im Nachhinein kann ich sagen,
ich habe v.a. ...
Ich war sehr ein junger,
unsicherer Mann.
Und ich habe einfach auch meine
Ängste damit zu verdrängen begonnen.
Ich wollte gewisse Gefühle ...
nicht annehmen.
Was mich als ... Süchtiger
sehr schnell ausgezeichnet hat, ist,
dass ich sehr schnell die Kontrolle
über meinen Konsum verloren habe.
Irgendwann hatte ich eine Nadel im
Arm - ich sagte, das mache ich nie.
Irgendwann habe ich auch gemerkt,
dass mich der Drogenkonsum zerstört,
mein Leben zerstört
und mich auch zu jemanden macht,
der ich nicht sein möchte.
Ich habe auch
all meine Werte verloren.
Irgendwann habe ich es
dann doch geschafft, aufzuhören.
Und zwar mit NA und diesen Meetings.
Ein wichtiger Satz, der mich
dann hier begleitet hat, ist:
"Es zählt nicht, wo ich war,
sondern wohin ich gehe."
* Rhythmische Streicherklänge *
Mein Kind ist im Heim. Meine Firma
ist mehr oder weniger ruiniert.
Mein Führerausweis ist weg,
mein Auto beschlagnahmt.
Wenn ich clean bin,
sehe ich das jeweils wieder.
Und das auszuhalten zu können,
und clean auszuhalten zu können,
ist unglaublich schwierig.
Was ich nicht kannte: das Konzept,
dass es hilft, darüber zu reden.
Für mich war nicht nahvollziehbar,
was das bringen sollte.
* Unverständliches Gespräch,
intensive, rhythmische Klänge *
Ich bin Adi und ich bin süchtig.
- (Alle) Hoi Adi.
Es ist schön, hier zu sein.
Ich war fünfmal im Entzug.
Ohne das Wissen, dass ich
vielleicht etwas ändern müsste.
Ich dachte, die müssten schauen,
dass sie etwas ändern.
Dafür ging ich zu den Ärzten und
liess mir Medikamente verschreiben
und Pläne aufstellen.
Ich versuchte, mich daran zu halten.
Aber die einzige Veränderung,
die ich als nötig empfand,
war,
dass ich einfach keine Drogen nehme.
Das reichte einfach nie.
Ich fing immer wieder an.
Ich konnte in den Kliniken
relativ gut aufhören,
bin immer clean ausgetreten,
aber nie clean geblieben.
Ich habe dort nie realisiert, dass
etwas bei mir falsch sein könnte.
Dass ich selber
das Problem sein könnte.
Das habe ich in all diesen Anläufen
nicht realisiert.
Adrian ist seit acht Jahren clean.
Er ist 43 Jahre alt
und erfolgreicher Geschäftsmann.
Er nahm Kokain und Heroin.
Es wurde innert kürzester Zeit
zum täglichen Konsum.
Und es ist ...
Mengenmässig
ging die Kurve nach oben,
emotional usw.
relativ schnell nach unten.
Das ist schon ...
Rückblickend ist es eindrücklich,
wie das funktioniert.
Es sind ... Ketten, die einen
umschlingen, und nichts geht mehr.
Im Büro kamen dann auch
kriminelle Handlungen dazu.
Ich brauchte natürlich Unsummen
an Geld für diesen Lebensstil.
Und ...
Ich legte im Geschäft
fiktive Mitarbeiter an.
Habe ihnen den Lohn ausgezahlt
und meine Kontodaten hinterlegt.
Ja, es war nicht ohne.
Es hat Dimensionen angenommen,
die längst nicht mehr lustig waren.
Es war wirklich jeder Bereich
meines Lebens betroffen.
* Stimmungsvolle,
perlende Klaviermusik *
Wie habt ihr als Freunde
seinen Absturz mitgekriegt?
Habt ihr es überhaupt mitgekriegt?
(Frau)
Ich hab's zuerst mitgekriegt, oder?
Ich habe es erst nicht mitgekriegt.
(Mann) Ich auch nicht,
ich war der letzte, der es merkte.
Vielleicht, weil er mir gegenüber
immer Termine eingehalten hat.
Das war etwas, was ihr bemerkt hat:
Er war unzuverlässig.
In dieser Zeit haben wir uns
seltener zum Jassen getroffen.
Solche Dinge wurden seltener.
Wir haben uns nicht geachtet,
es wurde einfach seltener.
Wir fragten nicht nach,
waren selbst beschäftigt.
Wir haben es echt zu spät gemerkt.
Ich habe es einfach sonst gemerkt.
Aber wir waren uns von dieser
Konstellation auch am nächsten.
Ich habe ihn
ein paarmal darauf angesprochen.
Auch ganz konkret:
"Nimmst du Drogen?"
Du hast immer verneint, bis auf
einmal, aber erst ziemlich spät.
Dieser Mechanismus, dass ich meine
Sucht bis auf den Tod verteidige,
der war so stark.
Dieses Lügenkonstrukt,
das mit dieser Krankheit einhergeht,
ist in dem Moment überlebenswichtig,
in meiner Wahrnehmung.
Wenn es jemand herausfindet,
ändert sich alles,
dann verliere ich
die ganze Kontrolle.
Nach seinem dritten Entzug
wurde Adrian Vater.
Die Mutter des Kindes
war ebenfalls drogensüchtig.
Während der Schwangerschaft
bekam sie kontrolliert Methadon.
Ich erlebte die Geburt noch clean.
Der Sohn musste aber sofort
vom Gebärsaal in die Neonatologie,
weil sie auch noch substituiert war.
Als erstes im Leben
durfte er einen Entzug durchmachen.
Das war extrem schwierig auszuhalten
und zu akzeptieren
und zu wissen:
Das ist unser Verschulden.
Er kann nichts dafür und ist
einfach Opfer dieses Konstruktes.
Es ging alles gut,
er hat es gut gemeistert
und ging dann mit ihr
zurück in die Therapieinstitution.
Und dann wurde einer von uns beiden
zuerst wieder rückfällig.
Und der Rattenschwanz begann erneut.
Und obwohl du einen Sohn hattest ...
Das war nicht stark genug?
Diese Frage ist sehr schwierig,
ob ...
... es nicht gereicht hat.
Nein, hat es nicht. Hat es nicht.
Die Sucht ist grösser.
Nach vier kürzeren Entzügen
macht Adrian
eine siebenmonatige Langzeittherapie.
Dort lernt er NA kennen.
Das Konzept, das ich fuhr,
war natürlich auch totaler Irsinn.
Ich wurde nie alleine clean.
Aber mein Ansatz war, alleine clean
zu bleiben. Das kann ich schon.
Und das ist tief verankert
in den Leistungsmustern von früher.
Ich machte Einzelsportarten
und wollte als Sieger
vom Platz gehen.
Ich musste den Sieg
mir selbst zuordnen können.
Das war auch hier so,
ich wollte es alleine schaffen,
sonst war es nichts wert.
Aber dass ich nie alleine
clean wurde, blendete ich total aus.
Hier der Empfang.
- Das war auch noch anders.
Hier
fand mein erstes NA-Meeting statt.
Das ist ...
- Okay.
Dienstagabend,
nach dem Montagseintritt.
Also gleich am darauffolgenden Tag.
- Einen Tag danach, ja.
Kannst du dich noch erinnern,
wie es war, als du hier reinkamst?
War der Raum voll? Wer sass hier?
Es waren viele Mitklienten hier.
Und es kamen ein paar Externe.
Und ich dachte: "Hier
kommt niemand freiwillig rauf."
"Es stimmt also,
sie sind wirklich clean."
Die meistkonsumierte Droge bei NA
ist Alkohol,
gefolgt von Cannabis und Kokain.
So ist es auch
in der Gesellschaft allgemein.
Die Rückfallquote eines
Drogensüchtigen liegt bei über 90 %,
und trotzdem
suchen immer mehr Menschen
in den Räumen von NA nach Hilfe.
(Mann) Ist jemand das erste Mal hier
oder will sich einem neuen Teil
des Programms widmen
oder ist zurück von einem Rückfall?
* Applaus *
Dann kommen wir zum zweiten,
der orange.
Hat jemand einen Clean-Geburtstag?
30 Tage, heute oder letzte Woche?
Ist jemand zwischen einem Jahr
und 18 Monaten clean?
* Applaus *
Wer ist über zwei Jahre clean?
Ich wollte früher immer Tattoos,
wusste aber nicht, was.
Und die sind eigentlich alle
in der Drogenzeit entstanden,
die meisten auch irgendwann nachts,
von irgendjemandem,
irgendwo, irgendwie.
Sandra ist 34 Jahre alt. Seit
sieben Monaten lebt sie drogenfrei.
Sie hat einen jüngeren Bruder.
Ihre Eltern sind seit 40 Jahren
glücklich verheiratet.
Sie sagt,
ihre Kindheit sei behütet gewesen.
Trotzdem beginnt sie früh in ihrer
Jugend exzessiv Alkohol zu trinken.
Sie haben bei mir das ADHS
mittlerweile auch diagnostiziert.
Das Aufmerksamkeitsdefizit habe ich
weniger, mehr die Hyperaktivität.
Ich war immer
mit voller Leidenschaft dabei.
Ich machte etwas gerne,
dann wollte ich alles machen.
Dann mochte ich das Nächste,
und dann war das alles.
Wir kifften als Teenies ab und zu,
nahmen Medikamente, um aufzuput-
schen, wegzumachen, was auch immer.
Ich sagte aber früh: "Wenn ich
jemals Drogen nehme, dann Kokain."
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Ich bin niemand, der gerne chillt.
Am Anfang hat es ... überwog
für mich der positive Effekt.
Es hat mich einerseits wach gehalten
und aufgeputscht,
aber auch innerlich beruhigt.
Das Chaos in meinem Kopf.
Dort herrscht ein Wahnsinn,
der schwer erklärbar ist.
Es ist so viel Lärm,
so laut und anstrengend.
Mit dem Koks war es sortierter.
Es war irgendwie ...
Es war nicht mehr alles zerstreut,
sondern etwas mehr kanalisiert.
Und dieses grauenhafte Gefühl
von Leere,
das sich bei mir über die Jahre
gesteigert hat, wurde genommen.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Ich kriegte Depressionen. Ich konnte
morgens nicht mehr aufstehen.
Alles, was vor mir lag,
der Tag, war immer zu viel.
es war nicht mehr auszuhalten
oder zu ertragen.
Dadurch ... Das war das Eine.
Dieses Gefühl der Unmeisterbarkeit
von allem.
Und dann auch gesundheitlich.
Du versaust dir dein Immunsystem.
Ich hatte kein Gefühl mehr für mich
und meinen Körper, war oft krank.
Mein Knie war damals kaputt.
Ich bemerkte die Schmerzen meist
nicht, weil das Kokain sie betäubte.
Es ist einfach eine psychische
und körperliche Abwärtsspirale.
Nach einem gescheiterten Selbstentzug
bei ihren Eltern
geht sie in eine Klinik.
Dort stellt sich die NA vor.
Sandra fühlt sich angesprochen.
Seither
besucht sie fast täglich ein Meeting.
Seit ich regelmässig
in die Meetings gehe,
seit ich täglich Meetings besuche,
habe ich eine
riesige Veränderung durchgemacht.
Ich habe gelernt, ehrlich zu sein.
Ich muss nicht mehr lügen.
Ich darf ehrlich sein
und sagen, was ich fühle und denke.
Das etwas vom Schönsten.
Ich habe acht Jahre lang
nicht gesagt, was ich dachte.
Ich konnte nicht mehr sprechen.
Ich hatte mich
in mir selber eingesperrt.
Und jetzt ist es schön zu sehen,
wie sich auch alles
in der Familie verändert.
Das Verhältnis zu meiner Mutter
wird wieder schön.
Wir können
respektvoll miteinander umgehen.
Ich bin nun am ersten Schritt,
den ich bald teilen darf.
Dafür bin ich unheimlich dankbar.
Ich habe geschlossen.
NA basiert
auf einem Zwölf-Schritte-Programm.
An diesen zwölf Schritten
arbeiten die Mitglieder
ausserhalb der Meetings.
(Mann) Hier sind die Schritte, die
unsere Genesung ermöglicht haben.
Erster: "Wir gaben zu, dass wir un-
serer Sucht gegenüber machtlos waren
und unser Leben
nicht mehr meistern konnten."
Dritter: "Wir trafen eine Entschei-
dung, unseren Willen und unser Leben
der Fürsorge Gottes, so wie wir
ihn verstanden, anzuvertrauen."
Achter:
"Wir machten eine Liste
aller Personen,
denen wir Schaden zugefügt hatten,
und wurden bereit,
ihn bei allen wieder gutzumachen."
Zwölfter: "Nachdem wir
als Ergebnis dieser Schritte
ein spirituelles Erwachen
erlebt hatten,
versuchten wir, diese Botschaft
an andere Süchtige weiterzugeben
und unser tägliches Leben nach
diesen Prinzipien auszurichten."
"Dies alles hört sich
wie eine riesige Aufgabe an
und wir können dies sicherlich
nicht auf einmal bewältigen."
"Wir wurden schliesslich
auch nicht in einem Tag süchtig."
"Deshalb heisst es ..."
- (Alle) "Hab Geduld".
Wenn in der Literatur
von Gott die Rede ist,
ist NA dann etwas Religiöses?
Es ist gar nicht religiös.
Es ist spirituell.
Religiös würde bedeuten,
es gibt eine bestimmte Vorstellung
davon, wie dieser Gott sein soll.
Die Worte Gott oder höhere Macht
kommen vor, um es zu umschreiben.
Aber auch immer der Zusatz:
"So wie wir ihn verstehen."
D.h., es ist eine ganz persönliche,
intime Angelegenheit.
Bei gewissen Leuten
kann das der Glaube sein.
Aber viele von uns
haben mit herkömmlichen
Glaubensbildern nicht viel am Hut.
Meine Sponsorin bringt auch
immer gerne als Beispiel:
Die grösste NA-Gemeinschaft ist in
den USA, die zweitgrösste im Iran.
Von den Glaubensgemeinschaften her
christlich und muslimisch geprägt.
Also zwei
ganz unterschiedliche Religionen.
Und bei beiden
funktioniert dieses Programm.
Ein erfahreneres NA-Mitglied, eine
sog. Sponsorin, bietet Unterstützung.
Auch bei der Umsetzung
der zwölf Schritte.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
"Schritt 1: Die Krankheit Sucht".
"Was bedeutet die Krankheit Sucht
für mich?"
"Sucht bedeutet für mich:
Einsamkeit, Hoffnungslosigkeit,
Dunkelheit, Zwang, Teufelskreis."
Was ist der Unterschied
zu einer Therapie,
in der du eine Psychologin
neben oder vis-a-vis von dir hast?
Ich mache nach wie vor Therapie.
Das ist ... Das hilft mir auch.
Sarah hat
eine ganz andere Herangehensweise.
Sie ist selber betroffen. Sie kann
mir mit ihren Erfahrungen helfen.
Das ist für mich
ein unschätzbarer Mehrwert.
Bei mir in der Nähe
gibt es viele dieser 24-h-Läden etc.
Ich ging jeden Tag in einen anderen,
damit das, was ich dort kaufte,
was meistens nur Alkohol war ...
Damit das nicht so auffiel.
(Frau) Du hast sehr viel Aufwand be-
trieben, um den Schein zu wahren.
Ja.
- Und die Flaschenentsorgung.
* Sandra lacht. *
Wenn eine Frau wirklich in Not ist,
ruft sie an und sagt, dass sie
ein Problem hat, und teilt es.
Ihr hilft dann schon nur eine klare,
ruhige Stimme. Jemand, der zuhört.
Ich muss gar nicht
so viel Krasses machen.
Wenn mich die Frauen wollen,
bin ich da.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Ich wohne nun
seit knapp zwei Jahren hier.
Als ich hierher gezogen bin,
fand ich es toll.
An der Langstrasse habe ich gear-
beitet und war ich immer unterwegs.
Am Anfang von NA war ich nicht si-
cher, ob das noch ein guter Ort ist.
Sandra arbeitet im Kulturbereich.
Und am Wochenende
hinter der Bar eines Klubs.
Seit sie keine Drogen mehr nimmt,
hat sie den Job hinter der Bar
aufgegeben.
Wenn du nun hier entlanggehst,
machst du neue Erinnerungen
oder kommen die alten
noch schubweise hoch?
Ja, das schon. Es sind Plätze
und Orte, an denen du denkst ...
Auch nach und nach. Vieles aus mei-
nem Leben weiss ich auch nicht mehr.
Die waren 20 Jahre lang im Nebel.
Und plötzlich fällt mir wieder ein:
"Ui, dort hast du gelegen", oder:
"Oh nein, da hast du das gemacht."
Aber
ich habe diese Angst nicht mehr.
Schon nach einem guten halben Jahr
ist diese Angst weg.
Weil ich weiss:
Wenn ich so weitermache wie heute,
muss ich nie mehr dorthin.
Und das ist ein schönes Gefühl.
Die Sucht beeinflusst
alle Bereiche ihres Lebens.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Gelitten hat v.a.
die Beziehung zu ihrem Bruder.
Als sie noch Drogen nahm,
hatten sie zusammen gewohnt.
Er hatte es aber
nicht mehr ausgehalten und zog aus.
Für mich ist das ein Thema, über das
ich nicht immer diskutieren mag.
Denn ich bin
nicht selber betroffen
und kann mich
nicht richtig hineinversetzen,
und deshalb spreche ich mit dir
lieber über andere Themen.
Ich habe ihr das noch nie gesagt.
- Ja, das wollte ich gerade sagen.
Es ist ... Man darf schon
über dieses Thema reden.
Ich habe mir aber
von diesem Dreh auch erhofft,
dass das mal zur Sprache kommt.
Ich finde das sehr wertvoll.
Denn ich habe irgendwie
immer noch das Gefühl,
ich müsse zeigen, dass alles gut
ist. Ich bin clean, ich mache das.
Es ist gut,
haben wir das ausgesprochen,
denn ich bin nicht scharf drauf,
immer wieder darüber zu reden.
Das müsstest du vielleicht
auch mal Mami und Papi sagen.
Denn sie stellen viele Fragen dazu
und ich finde ...
... dort müsste wieder Normalität
rein. Du hast ein anderes Leben.
Sandra ist zwar clean - und trotzdem:
Die Drogen sind noch sehr präsent.
Ich denke jeden Tag an Drogen.
Aber ich habe
dieses Reissen nicht mehr.
Diesen inneren Zwang,
das Gefühl, ich müsse Drogen nehmen.
Das ist wirklich
schon viel besser geworden.
Die grosse Mehrheit der Menschen
konsumiert Drogen
auf unproblematische Art.
Rund ein Viertel jener,
die Drogen nehmen, hat Probleme.
Und diese Probleme sind sehr heftig.
Ärzte sind meist
die erste Anlaufstelle
eines drogensüchtigen Menschen.
Während im Ausland
die NA oft ins Therapieprogramm
von Kliniken integriert ist,
lässt sich in der Schweiz kaum
eine Klinik finden, die das tut.
Wäre es an den Ärzten,
die NA bekannter zu machen?
Die Klinik Im Hasel stellt der NA
zwar einen Raum zur Verfügung,
aber ein obligatorischer Teil der
Therapie ist das NA-Meeting nicht.
Welche Lücke kann NA schliessen,
die Sie als Arzt nicht füllen können?
Dieser Kontakt
des Persönlich-betroffen-seins.
Wir haben immer
den professionellen Blick.
Wir sind selber nicht betroffen.
Und das können wir
überhaupt nicht geben.
Auch die persönliche Bindung.
Natürlich versuchen wir, in der
Therapie eine Bindung herzustellen.
Aber das ist in der Regel
eine Bindung mit einem Anfang,
einem Programm, das läuft, und dann
hat sie oft wieder ein Ende.
Bei den NAs gibt es eine persönliche
Bindung, die deutlich mehr anbietet.
Die ist eigentlich auf Lebenszeit
ausgelegt. Das können wir nicht.
Auch die Verfügbarkeit,
jederzeit anrufen zu können.
Wir haben unsere Öffnungszeiten,
unser Notfallprozedere.
Das können wir so nicht anbieten.
NA umfasst viel weitere Bereiche.
Wir schauen eher
auf dysfunktionale Verhaltensmuster,
soziale Reintegration,
sozialpsychiatrische Themen.
Aber nicht Freundschaft
und Lebensglück.
(Adrian) Für mich stellt sich
die Frage ... des Autonomieanteils.
Wie viel
ist ein Süchtiger in der Lage -
zum Zeitpunkt, zu dem er in eine
stationäre Institution kommt -
selber zu entschieden, was er
möchte, was gut ist, was gesund ist.
Ich bin froh,
wurde ich in gewissen Bereichen
auch zu meinen Glück gezwungen,
denn alleine
hätte ich es nicht gefunden.
Und Sie sind da aber weniger pushy?
Wir zwingen niemanden.
Die Autonomie des selber Ent-
scheidens, Abwägens, Vorbereitens -
uns ist ganz wichtig, dass das
beim Patienten ist, nicht bei uns.
Thilo Beck vom Zentrum
für Suchtmedizin in Zürich
sieht den Abstinenzansatz der NA
kritisch.
Es ist schon
dieser alles-oder-nichts-Anspruch.
Entweder abstinent
oder es ist nicht gut.
Etwas übertrieben gesagt.
Diejenigen, für die das
nicht stimmt, die sich überlegen,
weiterhin kontrolliert
oder weniger zu konsumieren,
fühlen sich dann minderwertig oder
nicht diesen Vorgaben entsprechend.
Und das ist dann eher
ein kontraproduktiver Effekt.
Die Erkenntnis
der modernen Suchttherapie ist,
dass es eben nicht
einen Ansatz für alle gibt.
Waren Sie schon mal
an einem Meeting?
Ich persönlich war noch nie. Das
muss ich unbedingt noch nachholen.
Wieso waren Sie noch nie?
Sehen Sie, das ist diese Experten-
rolle, in der man manchmal verharrt.
Man geht vielleicht zu wenig raus.
Ich muss zugeben,
das fehlt noch in meinem Repertoire.
Die Abstinenz als nicht zeitgemäss.
Die Fachwelt stört sich
an diesem einseitigen Ansatz.
Doch kennen die Ärzte
die NA überhaupt?
Es lässt sich
praktisch kein Arzt finden,
der je an einem NA-Meeting war.
Ich frage mich:
Wäre es nicht sinnvoll, die NA
mehr ins Therapieangebot einzubinden?
Oder ist es tatsächlich
ein Programm für wenige?
Andre Seidenberg,
bekannt als Platzspitz-Arzt,
hat sich
auf Schwersüchtige spezialisiert.
Wieso interessieren sich die Ärzte
in der Schweiz nicht für die NA?
Wieso ich
mich nicht dafür interessiere:
Es war für die Klientel,
die bei mir im Vordergrund stand,
die am meisten Not hatte,
die am dringendsten, wirklich,
wirklich dringend Hilfe benötigte,
einfach nicht dasjenige Mittel,
das zielführend war.
Seidenberg
behandelte v.a. Opioidsüchtige,
also Menschen,
die Heroin konsumierten.
Ich denke, das kann schon für
Einzelne eine sehr gute Hilfe sein.
Bei Opioidabhängigen ist es das
eher nicht oder häufig nicht.
Denn wenn man einen Opioidabhängigen
in die Abstinenz drängt,
ist er in einer grösseren Gefahr,
als wenn er
eine dauerhafte Substitution hat,
also sprich Methadon
oder Morphin retard
oder halt auch mal Buprenorphin
oder was es dann ist.
Wenn er abstinent ist, kann er
plötzlich wieder rückfällig werden.
Dann wird es gefährlich,
denn dann hat er niemanden mehr,
dann hat er ja alle enttäuscht.
Und ist vielleicht auch
von sich selber sehr enttäuscht.
Und die Chance,
dass dann ein Todesfall eintritt,
die Chance, dass er dann
auf eine gefährliche Art konsumiert,
sprich: sich etwas spritzt
und vielleicht nicht sauber spritzt,
gebrauchte Nadeln verwendet usw..
Solche Situationen entstehen dann
und dann passiert das,
was dauerhafte Schäden
oder sogar den Tod zur Folge hat.
Die Leute, die es mit der NA ge-
schafft haben, abstinent zu werden -
da hat es
auch Opioidsüchtige darunter -
sagen Sie,
das sind alles krasse Einzelfälle?
Ich denke, wichtig ist, dass man
zehn Jahre und länger hinschaut.
Ich bin ein alter Arzt, einen alten
Drogenarzt könnten Sie mich nennen,
d.h.,
ich habe ganz lange hingeschaut.
Und es gibt auch
wissenschaftliche Untersuchungen,
gerade im Raum Zürich -
da konnte man wirklich beweisen,
dass 95 % einfach nie
dauerhaft aufhören können.
Das muss man mal
zur Kenntnis nehmen.
Das muss man
wirklich zur Kenntnis nehmen.
95 % fangen irgendwann wieder an.
Und dieses Wiederanfangen
ist eine ganz gefährliche Situation.
Darauf muss man zielen.
Mann kann nicht auf diese 5 % ...
Ich kenne auch solche. Ich kenne so
viele Leute, ich kenne auch solche.
Aber es ist sehr selten,
dass es langfristig gelingt.
Und man muss immer fragen:
zu welchem Preis?
Adrian, der Heroin nahm,
ist bereit, dieses Risiko einzugehen.
Im kontrollierten Drogenprogramm zu
bleiben, kam für ihn nicht in Frage.
Ich bin an einem Dienstagmorgen
ausgetreten.
Ich stand draussen auf dem Park-
platz. Meine Mutter holte mich ab.
Und das Gefühl war das gleiche
wie jeweils nach diesen drei Wochen.
Ich stand wieder
genauso verloren dort.
Ich hatte keine Ahnung,
was mich erwartet.
Automatisch kam Suchtdruck.
Und dann diese Spirale:
"Jetzt warst du
sieben Monate stationär,
hattest nie einen Rückfall,
hattest nicht mal Suchtdruck."
"Einmal mehr dieser Musterpatient."
"Und kaum lassen sie dich
in die Freiheit,
droht wieder alles abzustürzen."
Ich ging am gleichen Abend
an mein erstes Meeting.
Gefühlt ging ich dann
jeden Abend an ein Meeting.
Ich bin mega froh,
kann ich heute an ein Meeting.
Ich merke, ich bin momentan ...
den Tränen nahe.
Ich finde es gerade sehr schwierig,
mich selber anzunehmen,
denn ich bin in den letzten ...
... v.a. in den letzten zwei Tagen
wieder mit Verhaltensweisen
von mir selbst konfrontier worden,
die mir sehr weh machen,
wenn ich sie auslebe.
Sie schaden nicht nur mir,
sie schaden auch ... meiner Tochter.
Ich konnte nicht ruhig bleiben.
Ich hatte in einem Moment ...
die Geduld nicht.
Ich schäme mich nachher sehr.
Selbstannahme ist ... der Schlüssel
für mich, den ich hier gefunden habe
und für den ich sehr dankbar bin.
Wenn man das dann
rausträgt ins Leben:
Ich hatte vor Kurzem ein Erlebnis
mit meinem kleinen Siebenjährigen.
Wir kamen aus dem Ausland zurück.
Wir standen im Bus
und er hat eine Frau angerempelt.
Es war eine aktive Süchtige,
und sie hat ihm hinter seinem Rücken
den Stinkefinger gezeigt.
Und der Schöberli, der grosse, er-
fahrene Genesende, ist ausgerastet,
hat die Frau am Kragen gepackt,
sie zurechtgewiesen und gesagt:
"Mit meinem Bub
machst du das nicht!"
Mein kleiner Bub stand daneben und
schaute mich komplett entsetzt an.
Und ich habe das gemacht,
was ich heute kann -
ich weiss, das kann ich heute,
und ich habe es gemacht -
ich habe mich bei ihm entschuldigt
für mein Ausrasten,
für eine falsche Energie,
mit der ich reagiert habe.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Adrians Sohn Henry war im Alter von
zweieinhalb bis vier im Kinderheim.
Oswald Grünenfelder war damals
der Leiter von Henrys Wohngruppe.
Hallo, willkommen.
Schön, dass ihr hier seid.
Hast du gebacken?
- (Henry) Ja.
Mit deiner Grossmutter?
- Ja, mit Grossmami.
Megacool.
- Papi hatte keine Zeit.
Super.
Hier ist das Wohnzimmer.
Früher habe ich immer hier gespielt.
Oder z.B. hier mit den Eisenbahnen
eine grosse Eisenbahn gebaut.
Das war die Fernsehecke,
hier haben wir jeweils ferngesehen.
Hier war mein Zimmer.
Da ist jetzt jemand anderes drin.
Aber früher war auf dieser Seite
mein Bettchen, hier schlief ich.
Im Kinderheim Inselhof können Kinder
bleiben, bis sie neun Jahre alt sind.
Kinder aus belasteten Familien.
Häufig spielen Drogen eine Rolle.
Weisst du,
wieso du hier gewohnt hast?
Weil mein Mami und mein Papi ...
... in der Therapie waren - oder?
Und Papi hat ja ...
gearbeitet und hatte keine Zeit.
Und mein Mami war damals ...
immer in der Therapie.
Dann war ich halt immer hier bei Osi
und den anderen und hatte Spass.
Meine Eltern
kamen mich immer wieder besuchen
und dann freute ich mich mega,
wie jedes Kind.
Was ist Ihre Erinnerung an den Vater,
an Adrian?
Er ist mir in lebhafter Erinnerung.
Was mir geblieben ist:
Bei Sitzungen ... Alle drei Monate
haben wir eine Standortsitzung,
und er hat immer als Erstes -
ich sagte immer,
das erste Wort gehöre den Eltern:
Wie haben sie das Kind erlebt,
wie geht es ihnen?
Als erstes schaute er auf der Uhr,
welches Datum war.
Und dann sagte er auf den Tag genau,
wie lange er schon abstinent war.
Das hat mir immer
grossen Eindruck gemacht.
Ich erinnere mich.
Meine Clean-Zeit war mir wichtig.
Und auch, das ansprechen zu können.
Aber v.a., diese Offenheit
beibehalten zu können.
Ich fand es schwierig zu wissen,
dass mein Sohn hier lebt.
Und auch dieser Machtlosigkeit
permanent ausgesetzt zu sein.
Es ist ein Obhutsentzug,
bei dem man als Eltern
einfach nichts mitzureden hat.
Nichtsdestotrotz
hatte ich ein tiefes Vertrauen,
dass wir das
miteinander hinkriegen können,
wenn ich an mir arbeite
und die Mutter an sich arbeitet.
Im Inselhof erlebte ich nie, dass
ich fand, man arbeite gegen uns.
Bei früheren Institutionen
machte ich diese Erfahrung.
Das hatte etwas extrem Befreiendes.
Henrys Mutter ist immer noch
im kontrollierten Drogenprogramm.
Mithilfe seiner eigenen Mutter
kümmert sich Adrian um Henry.
Obwohl er seit acht Jahren clean ist,
ist auch er nicht sicher davor,
wieder Drogen zu nehmen.
Die Drogensucht
fesselt Süchtige ein Leben lang.
Dreimal pro Woche
geht Adrian in ein NA-Meeting.
Genesung
muss an erster Stelle stehen.
Das habe ich früher schon gehört,
wusste aber nicht, wie man es macht.
Heute glaube ich sogar,
dass das,
was ich über meine Genesung stelle,
das erste sein wird,
das ich wieder verlieren werde.
D.h. auch, mein Sohn
kommt nach meiner Genesung.
Denn er hat erlebt,
wie es war, als es umgekehrt war.
Und die Folgen sind verehrend.
Er war im Heim.
Heute ist es so,
dass die Arbeit an meiner Genesung
viel Zeit beansprucht.
Ich bin super stolz auf ihn,
muss ich sagen.
Das ist auch ein Grund, wieso ich
fand, man sollte hier mitmachen.
Es ist bestimmt nicht einfach.
Ich kann es mir nur vorstellen.
Aber ich bin sehr stolz auf das,
was er erreicht hat.
Wir merken das
manchmal auch beim Jassen.
Wenn jemand anruft -
Leute, die er betreut -
ist er da und hilft.
Dafür muss man zuerst
mit sich selbst im Reinen sein.
Ich finde das sehr beeindruckend.
Es ist müssig zu sagen:
"Was wäre, wenn?"
Vielleicht hätte ich auch auf dem
anderen Weg ein gutes Leben gehabt.
Einfach niemals so tiefgründig,
glaube ich.
Ich hätte das nicht gefunden,
wenn ich nicht angefangen hätte,
Drogen zu nehmen.
Das ist mir heute auch bewusst.
Ich musste wirklich
diesen unglaublichen Preis zahlen,
um einen Zugang zu finden
zu einem Programm,
das mir das gibt, was ich heute bin.
Wupp. Wuwupp.
Sorry! Bitte, Adieu, Merci.
Ent...
Äh, was hatten wir noch alles?
Ciao!
(Aus dem Off) Körperlich, geistig,
seelisch war ich bankrott.
Ich rede mit den Hunden, du Wixer.
Sali, hast du Hasch?
Ich bin ca. 1,85 m gross.
Gegen Ende
stand ich mal auf die Waage
und sie zeigte knapp über 45 an.
Ich war total verzweifelt.
Das irische Fernsehen
kam mal auf den Letten.
Sie haben mich interviewt
und immer wieder dasselbe gefragt.
Sie sagten: "Was machst du da?",
und ich ... Ich habe in meiner
damaligen derben Sprache gesagt:
"Ich mache einfach Scheisse.
Ich drücke mir Drogen rein."
"Wieso machst du das?"
"Ja, weil ich nicht aufhören kann."
"Wieso machst du immer weiter, wenn
du weisst, dass es scheisse ist?"
"Ich kann nicht aussteigen.
Ich weiss nicht, wie."
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Ich war das sechste
von sechs Kindern
innerhalb von fünfeinhalb Jahren.
Wenn ich an meine Kindheit
zurückdenke - das war sehr streng.
Wir mussten den Bürstenschnitt
machen, wir wurden nicht gefragt.
2-mm-Schnitt. Erzogen worden
sind wir mit Schlägen.
Ich musste auch oft zuschauen,
wie meine Brüder verprügelt wurden,
und ich wurde auch geschlagen,
und wirklich teilweise heftigst,
nicht nur einfach
mit der Hand ins Gesicht,
sondern mit Gürtel, Teppichklopfer
und dem ganzen Programm.
Es war schon sehr ... Es war
sehr eng und streng und rigid.
Mein Vater war oft weg,
besoffen, hat viel gearbeitet.
Ging jassen, ging saufen.
Meine Mutter war zu Hause,
depressiv.
Hat angefangen, morgens Schlaf-
tabletten mit Rotwein einzunehmen
und sich dann
wieder ins Bett zu legen.
Das ist alles
ein bisschen aus dem Ruder gelaufen.
Meine Geschwister haben alle
irgendwie die Kurve gekriegt.
Warum sich der Wurm
bei mir so gekrümmt hat,
kann ich gar nicht so genau sagen,
und darum geht es auch nicht.
Ich möchte auch nicht
Schulzuweisungen machen
gegenüber meinen Eltern,
das bringt mich nicht weiter.
Aber aus der jetzigen Position
muss man sagen:
Ich war wohl einfach
ein sehr sensibles Kind.
Fast 20 Jahre lang nahm Roman Drogen.
Alle möglichen Drogen.
Seit 24 Jahren ist er clean.
Das letzte halbe Jahr
habe ich hier gewohnt.
Und tatsächlich dann,
als der Letten geräumt wurde,
am 15. Februar 1995,
habe ich angerufen beim Entzug. Und
sie haben gesagt: "Kannst kommen."
Dann habe ich
einen 110-l-Abfallsack gepackt
und den gefüllt mit meinen alten,
ungewaschenen Kleidern
und meinen Mahnungen
und Betreibungen
und bin am 15. Februar am Morgen
früh hier raus und in den Entzug.
Ich bin Roman und bin ein Süchtiger.
- (Alle) Hoi Roman.
Ich habe unterdessen Kinder.
Der Bub ist 15, das Mädchen 13.
Meine Schwiegermutter hat einen
Riesensack voller teurer Kleider
für meine Tochter angeschleppt.
Sie hat ihr das alles
im Zimmer präsentiert.
Meine Tochter hat am Schluss
zwei kleine Pullöverchen genommen,
den Rest nicht.
Mich hat das geärgert
und ich habe am Nachmittag beim Ku-
chenessen Witzchen darüber gemacht,
was die 13-Jährigen
heute anziehen dürfen und was nicht.
Dieser Gruppendruck,
was cool ist und was nicht.
Und plötzlich gegen Abend, als ich
mit meiner Frau sprach, merkte ich:
Das hat mein Vater immer gemacht.
Er hat uns so beschämt.
Und plötzlich wurde mir klar:
Das ist super.
Da sind Verwandte,
die viel Geld haben, Klamotten,
und meine Tochter
hat einfach Nein gesagt.
Sagte, was sie wollte und was nicht.
Und das übe ich ja
eigentlich mit ihr,
dass sie nicht Mitläuferin ist
und Nein sagen kann.
Es war super,
ich konnte ins Zimmer und sagen:
"Ich muss kurz mit dir sprechen.
Es tut mir leid."
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
* Unverständliches Gespräch *
Wie ist dein Papi?
Wenn du ihn beschreiben müsstest?
Er macht immer viele Spässe, die
meistens gar nicht so lustig sind.
(Lachend) Pass auf, was du sagst!
Aber ich lache dann
manchmal trotzdem,
weil sie so unlustig sind,
dass sie wieder lustig sind.
Seine Ehefrau und die Kinder
wissen von seiner Vergangenheit.
Es ist gut, dass ich es weiss.
Mich stört es nicht,
weil ich ihn ja nie so erlebt habe.
Wie ist es für dich,
wenn das in der Familie
oder mit den Kindern Thema ist?
Ich habe schon überlegt,
ob und wem ich es sagen soll.
Soll ich das ... Soll ich so tun,
als wäre es gar nie passiert?
Ich habe mich
für einen offenen Weg entschieden.
Mein Freundeskreis ... Darunter sind
viele, die bei den NA dabei sind.
Genau.
Ja. Und das ist wichtig für mich.
Dass ich das auch wertschätze.
Auch die Cleangeburtstage. Das hat
eine gewisse Bedeutung für mich.
Bis vor einem halben Jahr
hatte Roman noch Hepatitis C.
Eine Leberkrankheit, vermutlich
verursacht durch verschmutzte Nadeln.
Ein abstinentes Leben
war für ihn anfangs unvorstellbar.
Meine Idee war tatsächlich, dass ich
zwischen drei und sechs Monate
zwischen mich
und die Drogen bringen muss.
Dann kann ich wieder beginnen
mit weichen Substanzen.
Und wenn ich das im Griff habe,
kann ich ab und zu sogar
wieder etwas härteres Zeug nehmen.
Das war eigentlich der Plan.
Ich habe dann im Verlauf der ersten
paar Jahre, als ich clean war,
so viele Leute
in diese Meetings kommen sehen,
die sich gegen Schluss
gemeldet haben und gesagt haben,
dass sie sich total schämen,
weil sie einen Rückfall hatten.
Es sei vom ersten Moment an
völlig scheisse gewesen,
als sie das Zeug genommen haben.
Und etwa nach dem 10., 15. Mensch -
immer genau dieselbe Geschichte -
ist bei mir
plötzlich der Groschen gefallen:
Wieso sollte es bei mir anders sein?
Ich merkte irgendwann: Das war
das erste Mal in meinem Leben,
dass ich nicht undbedingt eine nega-
tive Erfahrung selbst machen muss,
sondern von den Erfahrungen anderer
profitieren kann.
Auch wenn es negative sind.
Am Anfang musste ich innerlich
immer vorbereiten, was ich sage.
Mit der Zeit machte ich dann
plötzlich die Erfahrung:
Ich spürte ein Gefühl,
dass etwas kommt,
dass etwas gestaut ist - ich wusste
noch nicht mal genau, was.
Und ich fange einfach an mit:
"Ich bin Roman und ich bin süchtig."
Dieser Spruch mit dem Namen und "ich
bin süchtig", wie wichtig ist der?
Der klingt total komisch
in den Ohren einer Person,
die das nicht kennt.
Es gibt auch an, wer gerade spricht.
Gleichzeitig
ist es auch eine Erinnerung daran,
dass ich süchtig bin und ...
die Entscheidung getroffen habe,
nichts mehr nehmen zu wollen,
weil ich nicht damit umgehen kann.
Mit 32 war Roman zwar drogenfrei,
aber auch IV-Rentner ohne Ausbildung.
Er schloss eine Schreinerlehre
mit Berufsmatura ab
und schaffte den Einstieg
in einen sozialen Beruf.
Das hier
war seine erste Arbeitsstelle.
Oh, hallo Roman!
Schön, dass du da bist.
Hallo, ich bin Susanne.
- Hallo, ich bin Annette.
Wir haben oft
mit den Kindern Gespräche geführt,
wenn es schwierige Situationen gab.
Das ist mir am stärksten geblieben.
Und das hat gut funktioniert.
Diese beiden Seiten, ein Mann
und eine Frau, die gesprochen haben.
Das war richtig gut.
Schön, ja.
Ich habe gemerkt,
als ich hier gearbeitet habe,
dass ich grundsätzlich
gut mit Menschen umgehen kann.
Dass ich sie gut verstehe
und abholen kann.
So ist dann auch
der Wunsch entstanden,
weiter zu gehen und in diesem
Bereich eine Ausbildung zu machen.
Es hat sich klar gezeigt,
dass dir das Spass und Freude macht
und funktioniert mit den Kindern.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Auch nach 24 Jahren ohne Drogen
geht Roman einmal in der Woche
in ein NA-Meeting.
Wieso gehst du heute
immer noch in Meetings?
Nach einer Woche Familie,
Arbeit, Stress oder was auch immer,
komme ich dorthin
und komme einfach innerhalb
von 10 Min. runter und zu mir.
Und ich komme zu Lösungen,
wie ich mit meiner Frau wieder
weiterreden kann.
Indem ich im Meeting sitze
und bald merke,
dass  i c h  etwas ändern muss -
ich kann nicht warten,
bis sich jemand anderes ändert.
Das funktioniert einfach nicht.
Das wird dort so klar.
* Rhythmische, entspannte Musik *
Bist du heute sicher davor,
je wieder Drogen zu nehmen?
Nein. Nein, das bin ich nicht.
- Wieso nicht?
Ach ... Einerseits
habe ich ganz viele Beispiele.
Mein erster Sponsor
fand es nach 15 Jahren intensiver
Zugehörigkeit eine gute Idee,
wieder einmal
ein bisschen Wein zu trinken,
und zwei oder drei Monate später
ist er gestorben, weil er
eine Überdosis eingenommen hat.
Ich kenne mich selbst auch,
ich weiss, wie ich funktioniere.
Ich merke das
in ganz verschiedenen Feldern
meines Lebens und meiner Erfahrung.
Ich habe die Erfahrung gemacht,
dass ich eine solche Struktur
in mir angelegt habe.
Das würde einfach nicht gut kommen.
Die Drogensucht ist eine Last,
die Süchtige
ein Leben lang tragen müssen.
Sie kann zwar leichter werden -
ganz weg geht sie nie.